Hi everyone. How you all doing? Thank
you for uh coming today. Um I'm going to
be talking about how markdown is
basically the new code. Uh as TJA has
already sort of previewed um we recently
replaced a lot of code in the cursor
application with just markdown just a
skill and in today's talk I'm going to
share a bit of the journey of going from
a fullblown feature with a lot of code a
lot of dependencies a lot of complexity
and tests into a much more lightweight
streamdown version of the same feature
effectively but just with a single
skill.
Um, before I start though, I have to
give you guys a little recap of git word
trees and how they work in cursor. Now,
if you haven't heard of word trees in
git, they're effectively like um
separate checkouts. And I'm sorry for
the wide screen um but they're
effectively like like separate checkouts
of your repos that allow you to work in
parallel. So different agents can be
working on the same task at the same or
on different tasks at the same time
without um interfering with each other.
If you've never used this feature before
in cursor, the way it works is that you
can spin up an agent on an individual
work tree. Um, and you will see, for
example, the same file
in two different work trees. And you can
see that they look different because the
agent is doing some work on on the work
tree, but not on your primary checkout.
And anytime the agent runs commands or
lints or anything it does will be
isolated and scoped to that git word
tree.
Um, with this feature, you can also um
work even in parallel at the same time
on the screen. you can have like these
grids of agents working for you. Um, and
if you say, "Hey, open a PR," the agent
will open a pull request from that work
tree with the changes that it produced
inside that work tree. And one of the
coolest things about this feature is
that it allows you to give the same task
even to different models at the same
time and then compare what different
models do on the same prompt. So if you
haven't heard of this, we call it best
event and it's effectively a way for you
to compete on on diff have have
different models compete on the same
task and then you can even preview the
changes if it's a front-end um project
you're working on. Uh you can um compare
all the different visual implementations
and then choose the one you prefer. Now,
if you have never heard about this all
everything I'm talking about today, um I
will also just say that it all came out
in around October of last year alongside
cursor 2.0.
Um and when we initially shipped that,
it came with a lot of complexity. Um we
had to write all the code for creating
word trees, managing these word trees,
feeding them into the agent as context.
We also had to make sure that the agents
were scoped and isolated and they could
not escape the work tree they were
working on. Uh we also have something
called setup scripts which users can
configure and run uh and and have cursor
run them anytime an Asian starts
operating on a given word stream. We
also have the judging. So I didn't show
you this before, but uh there's a little
thumbs up icon on one of the models.
That's just a judge that we run um that
tells you which implementation looks the
best based on um different criteria. Uh
and then we also had to make some
changes to the harness uh and introduce
some system reminders to help the agent
stay on track in these word trees. And
then finally, there's some cleanup
complexity as well because people like
to spin up hundreds of these word trees
and then their disk sizes blow up and we
have to help them by cleaning up the um
the the word trees that stay behind.
Now, in our new implementation, the one
that I'm going to be talking about
today, we were able to get rid of most
of these things. And in fact, I recently
opened a PR uh removing this entire
feature from cursor and it was a massive
like deletion of of of code like I think
it was around 15,000 lines of code
deleted. The new implementation of the
feature is
almost as good as the previous one. um
and it is much much more lightweight in
terms of us to maintain it. Um and it
even has some benefits compared to the
previous implementation that I'll be
talking about today. So how were we able
to replace an entire feature with a
skill?
We decided that there are two primitives
that we could use to effectively allow
cursor users to use word trees by simply
leveraging two primitives. one is Asian
skills and the other are sub Asians. So
both of these are existing cursor
features. You can learn more about them
in our docs. Uh we have a page for
skills and we have a page for sub
Asians. And we realized that if we took
these two things together, we could
basically reimplement
both the cursor work feature as well as
the cursor best event feature with just
markdown. And this is a little video of
how it works. So I can now as a user say
slashwork tree and then I'll give it
some task. I'll say fix a typo in the
footer of the website and this agent
will run in an isolated word tree and do
its work there. So the way the skill is
written is actually really simple. I can
show you most of it. Uh it doesn't fit
on the screen but it's basically a set
of instructions telling the model um how
to create word trees and um to run the
setup scripts that the user might have
configured. and then to stay on that
checkout, right? We want to make sure
that when the agent is operating on a
word tree, it is staying in that
checkout. Um the best event skill is
very similar. It's actually even
smaller. The entire skill fits on the
screen here with with a small uh font.
Um, and what we're doing here is we're
instructing the parent agent to go and
create sub agents for each model and
then spin up a word tree for each uh, so
have each sub agent create its own work
tree and work inside that work tree. Um,
and then we also tell it to wait for all
the subs and when they're done, please
provide some commentary. Please let the
user know um what um the different
implementations by the different sub
agents look like. Maybe you can grade
them. Maybe you can make some uh
criticism of them and maybe you can help
the user choose which one is the best.
Um and and please give that to the user
in some nice table format or something.
But again, it's only around 40 lines of
code and it's all marked down. Like it's
not even code. And the previous version
of this was maybe 4,000 lines of code.
Some of the considerations we have to
have in this in the skill is that the
skill must be crossplatform compatible
like we have Windows specific
instructions and we have Linux and Mac
OS instructions as well. We also
instruct the parent model to run the
setup scripts for each word tree that
the user might have configured. And then
this is the hardest part. We'll spend a
bit of time on this on the talk today.
We have to instruct the model to stay on
that word tree, right? we have to really
say, hey, do not ever work outside this
and do not ever um escape, right? Um
and we we do that with some aggressive
prompting effectively.
So the new commands are slashword tree
and then slashpass event to do the basic
basically like um the to start agents in
isolated work trees and to start
multiple agents on the same task. And
then we also have apply word tree and
delete word tree to bring over changes
from the side word tree into your
primary checkout. And delete work tree
just does uh what you would expect. Uh a
little note is that these are not
actually skills in cursor. They're
actually commands but the way these
commands work in cursor is extremely
similar to how skills work in that there
the prompts only get loaded into the
context if the user chooses to load
them. Um, and the only reason we did it
as commands and not as skills is so that
the prompts for them can be controlled
in our servers in our back end. This
means I can iterate on these prompts um
without you having to update your cursor
version. Um, if I do some improvements
to these prompts, the next time you use
them, you're going to have you're going
to get the latest version of the
prompts. But effectively, they work like
skills. Um this is a demo of the best
event um skill or command where I'm
giving the same task to Kimmy Grock
composer GPT and opus and what you will
see is that the parent agent starts by
spinning up five sub agents on the five
different models that I specified and
each one is going to have its own work
tree. Each each one has its own context
and then opus takes a little longer as
expected and then at the end the parent
model as instructed will do that
comparison ac across all the different
subsations. It'll say um these two
models did basically the same thing.
This one did something that none of the
others did. And you can even talk to the
parent agent and you can say oh I like
this part that Opus did and I like this
part that GPT did. Can you can you match
them together? and the the parent agent
will do that for you.
Um, so let's talk about some of the pros
of the new implementation and then I'll
talk about some of the some of the the
the cons, some of the things we lost um
with this refactor. So the main pro of
reimplementing this entire feature as a
skill is that I have a lot less code to
maintain. Uh selfishly, um I'm going to
be spending a lot less time maintaining
this feature. And this is an an advanced
feature, right? We're not talking about
a feature that is used by 90% of cursors
users. Far from it. Work trees are kind
of an advanced thing. Um and so only the
cursor power users that love paralyzing
and having these grids of agents are
using work trees. So it's not the kind
of feature where we want to be spending
a lot of time with maintenance.
Another advantage is that our users can
now switch into a word tree halfway
through a chat. It was not possible
before. Um, we didn't want to pollute
the prompt UI too much with all these
like drop downs and settings. And so now
that it's just a slash command, it's
much easier for for users to switch to a
word tree halfway through a chat. They
can start talking about something and
then if they decide they want to work on
the site, they can do that with
slashword tree. Another big advantage is
that the previous implementation did not
work if you were working on multiple
repos at the same time. So it's very
common to have a multi-reo setup where
maybe your front end and your back end
are separate repos. In the past you
could not do word trees in this kind of
setup. It was just disabled. With the
new slashword tree command everything
works fine. the agent will make sure to
create a word tree on each repo and then
if you open a PR, it'll open two PRs,
one for each repo. It works quite well.
Another advantage of the new skill
implementation is that the judging
experience at the end of knowing what
model did which for best event is far
superior. The parent now has a lot more
context over what each of the sub aents
did. And the user can even ask the agent
to stitch together a little different
piece pieces and bits from the different
implementations which was not possible
before. In the previous implementation,
you had to choose one sub agent or one
model and just stick with that.
Now let's talk about some of the cons.
And if you're curious, um, we have a
forums link here where we're actually
getting some mixed feedback on the new
implementation. Like some people were
really accustomed to the old way of how
the feature used to work. Um, and if
you're curious, you can go and see that
not everyone is happy with the change,
at least for now. But we're we're
tracking. What are the problems? Number
one, it's very hard for the agent to
stay on track. With our previous
approach, um, the agent had to stay on
track. Like it, we didn't let the model
ever touch any files outside its work.
It was physically impossible for it to
do so. Now we're trusting the model. So
it's you could say it's a bit vibes
based because we're basically saying hey
operate on this directory and and and
then like you know knock on wood please
don't forget about this and especially
over long sessions it's quite possible
that the model will forget where it
should be operating and sometimes these
models especially the worst models will
kind of hallucinate or they'll go a bit
haywire and they'll start doing things
they shouldn't but we're we're working
on this. Um, another con is that it
feels slower because you're you're
seeing the agent create the work tree
and you're seeing that in your chat.
It's not actually slower, but it does
feel like the agent is kind of like
wasting time doing something that should
be done for it in advance. Um, we're
also looking at some improvements here.
And then finally, this is much harder to
find the feature now, right? Like before
whenever you opened cursor you had this
dropdown that would show you do you want
to run this task locally or do you want
to run it in cloud or do you want to run
it in a work tree now that entire
dropdown is gone and so if you want to
use work trees you have to know the
feature exists so you can actually type
/wart tree so the discoverability is a
bit worse but as I mentioned before this
is an advanced power user feature um
which
we're personally okay we're we're okay
with being less discoverable in general
So, how can we make this skill better?
Um, as I mentioned, the biggest problem
right now is that the agent is not
really always staying on track. Uh,
there's two ways that we're going to
improve this. One is with evals and then
using those evals to improve the prompts
and then the other one is through RL and
training. So, at cursor, we train our
own model called composer. And for
composer 2, our the latest version of
this model, we didn't have any RL tasks
with these prompts. We we didn't have
any tasks in all of the many many
thousands of tasks that we um use for RL
actually operating in this type of
environment. So we're working on adding
a bunch of these tasks into our RL
pipeline so that by the time we launch
composer three or four or five u at
least our own model will be much better
at this. Obviously we cannot improve the
models that the other companies develop
but we've been sharing feedback with all
the other labs and model providers on
this kind of thing. And for evals, uh
I've been working on some evals for this
feature and it was actually my first
time or not my first time but one I'm
I'm fairly um early in my u writing
evals uh journey and I was actually very
surprised if you use something like
brain trust and shout out to brain trust
they've been super helpful. Uh writing
these kinds of eval is is actually super
super easy. You don't have to know
almost anything about evals and you can
just prompt the agent. It'll do
everything for you. Um, effectively what
I'm doing is I spin up the cursor CLI.
It's headless, so it's great for evals.
Um, and then I have two scorers. One
that checks to see if the model did any
work in its work tree as expected and
then another one which is the reverse of
that which is did the model do any work
in the primary checkout where it
shouldn't be doing any work. Uh, and so
far the evals I've got are pretty
simple. So I actually haven't been
um able to simulate extremely long
sessions, which is when the models start
performing worse. But even so far, I've
already understood that not all models
are equally good at this. So for
example, haiku, which is a smaller, less
intelligent model, will very often
deviate and start working in the primary
checkup. But the other models that I've
been testing such as composer and grock
um are doing much better. So I still
have to improve these evals a lot more
to make them more complicated. But the
hope is that as soon as I can start to
find patterns here, I can actually go
and improve the prompts. And then
another thing we can do is have better
system reminders to the models uh
instructing them to stay on track and to
not deviate from the word tree that they
are supposed to be working in.
Okay. So, what's next? Um, the first
thing is we're actually going to take a
a small step back here and we're
actually going to have a much more
complete and native work trees
implementation in the new cursor agent
window. If you're uh if you've been
following, we recently announced cursor
3.0. Part of 3.0 0 is a more agentic
interface for coding where you can still
edit code and you can still see code but
the UI and the UX are much more
optimized around the agent and the chat
interface. We believe this kind of
interface is the right place for a
proper word trees implementation. The
kind of person who is more likely to be
uh doing a bunch of local paralization
is usually the same type of person that
is more likely to use this type of UI.
So we're taking a small step back there
and building a proper word trees uh
implementation that is more native not
so much agentic in the new UI. Also
we're improving the skills um as I
mentioned through this continued work on
evals and then RL and other training
work. And then finally we are actually
looking into other parallelization
primitives that are not git work trees.
So if you've used git work trees, you
might know that uh they can be a bit
slow to create. Um and also to
uh they also use up a lot of disk space
on your computer. Um and then finally uh
they only work in git repos. So if
you're using something other than git,
there's really no local paralization
primitive in cursor. Um in the near
future we hope to uh share more about
this but we're looking into some other
solutions for local paralization that
don't involve git and don't involve git
work trees. Um so yeah stay tuned for
that. Um thank you all for coming to the
talk today. Um I'm sure many of you have
questions and I'm going to be around all
day. Uh feel free to grab me anytime and
uh um I'm happy to chat with anyone.
Thank you.